( intro music )
( applause )
Good morning.
I hope it's all right to start
with a bit of controversy
that we need to double
food production by 2050
to feed the expected nine
billion people on the planet.
This is part of the
productionist ideology
that has driven the
agricultural frontier
into the world's
remaining forests.
I dispute that we need to
double food production.
Indeed, we have to ask
ourselves the question,
are we capable of it?
Yeah, I believe we are,
but at what cost
would that happen?
At the moment, the main
way in which we are
increasing production globally,
is to extend the
agricultural frontier,
and we have to remember
that food production
by taking over habitats and
turning it into our fields
is the single biggest
environmental impact
that humans have
had on the planet.
Does that mean we should
stop growing food?
No.
Does it mean we
have to grow food
in more sensitive
ways and use that food
that we do grow for what it
is which is embedded land,
embedded water,
embedded emissions,
embedded love and care.
If we take that attitude,
we don't need to double
food production by 2050
'cause we already grow
enough food on this planet
to feed 12 billion.
We need to use it more
carefully and waste less of it.
Green beans, they've
come to symbolize for me
some of the stupidities
in the global food system,
but also some of the
great opportunities
that actually exist and how
easy it is to tackle them.
I started my food
waste campaign actually
back when I was 15.
I was collecting food waste
from my school kitchens,
collecting these big yellow
buckets of swill, all the stuff
that my school friends had
turned their noses up at,
and I fed them to my pigs.
I went to the local baker,
and green grocer and markets,
and also to a farmer who
was throwing away potatoes
that were wrong shape or
size for the supermarkets.
That was great.
My pigs loved it.
They squealed every time
I came back from school
with these yellow buckets.
It was a very happy time.
My dad was growing vegetables,
and I had chickens.
I swapped manure
for his offcuts
from the vegetables
in his garden,
and it was a great system.
But most of the food
that I was collecting
was fit for human consumption,
and I knew I was just
scraping the surface.
I went on to start eating
a lot of this food myself,
good fresh food out of dumpsters
round the back of
the supermarkets.
I talked to those
supermarkets about
the food they were
putting in bins,
and couldn't they give
it to homeless charities?
Couldn't they sell it to their
customers for half price?
Even give it away
for free, do anything
but lock it in bins and send
it off to landfill sites.
They didn't want to
talk to me at that time.
So I started taking
things into my own hands,
taking them home and
eating that stuff.
I did it as a way
of demonstrating
that if someone like me who
can perfectly well afford
to buy food can
live off dumpsters,
something was very
wrong with the system.
I started taking
journalists, TV cameras
round the back of
supermarkets showing them
the sheer quantity of
food being put in there,
and that a lot of it was
still within its date.
Those dates themselves
were suspect.
So that really kicked off an
awareness-raising campaign.
We got a lot of press for that,
and it started this dialogue
first of all in
the United Kingdom,
and then increasingly
in other countries.
I eventually got round
to writing my second book
which was "The Waste:
Uncovering the
Global Food Scandal",
and I realized when
I and went and did
the global research, I
went around the world,
I went up and down
the supply chain,
that actually that
stuff from the back
of the dumpsters, that was
the tip of the iceberg.
And, in fact, most
of the food waste
that is occurring was further
up in the supply chain,
and principally on farms.
So when in 2013 we were
invited by the United Nations
Environment Program
to bring our positive
win-win solution promoting
campaigns to Kenya,
our challenge was to feed
the 500 environment ministers
and U.N. delegates in
Nairobi with food waste
sourced in Kenya.
Now you think, "Wow,
there are millions
of hungry people
in that country.
Surely, they're not
wasting food like
we are in the rest
of the world."
Sadly, we found that they are.
Not because of neglect or
because they don't care,
but because of first
of all infrastructure
and the lack of it on
small holder farms,
and secondly, and this is
where the beans come in,
the buying practices of
European supermarkets
who source their
horticultural products
from those countries.
It's a boom industry,
and a lot of people are
making a lot of money
in good ways growing good food.
I'm going to bring your
attention to the word trimmed
in this photograph.
You will notice, if anyone
who has grown beans,
that these beans
have been trimmed
not where they taper at the end
where they're getting
a bit thinner,
but right in the
middle of the bean.
That's because beans grow in
lots of different lengths,
and yet this plastic
carton is one length.
To get them into
these plastic cartons,
they're trimming the beans off,
sometimes 30 percent
of the bean off.
I visited farmers who were
wasting 30 to 40 percent
of the food they grow.
That's 30 to 40 percent
of the land and the water
used to grow that food
in a country where people
are going without land,
shifting their
agriculture further up
into the mountains,
chopping down more trees,
causing interruptions of
the hydrological cycle.
I visited depots
exporting beans to Europe
who were wasting 20
tons a day at least
of good fresh food.
All of that I would
have been very proud
to grow on my own allotment,
but they're wasting it,
and the contractors who
come and collect this waste
to feed to cattle
have to sign a contract
saying that they won't feed
any of this food to people.
That's a crime.
We took this evidence to
some of the supermarkets
who were implicated
in this supply chain,
and we showed them
what we had seen.
They undertook to change their
policies over that night.
They knew how embarrassing
it was going to be
if this kind of thing
got to their consumers.
We'd also talked
to the supermarkets
about the bananas they
were going to waste.
Again, cosmetic standards.
Bananas, when you go into a shop
they're all in perfect bunches,
they're all the same size,
they've all got exactly
the same curvature.
They're the same diameter.
Bananas don't grow like that.
In order to achieve
that uniformity,
all the ones that don't
comply get discarded.
This is the waste of
one banana plantation
after one day of
harvest in Ecuador.
Bananas being wasted
in Costa Rica.
When I first visited a carrot
production unit in England,
I remember going into the yard
and seeing this great big bin,
a little bit like this
one, full of carrots.
I said, "Oh, these must
be your premium carrots
going to the supermarkets."
"No, these are the waste ones."
"Why? What's wrong
with these carrots?
They're better than any
carrots I've ever grown."
He held it up to the light,
and he said, "You can see
there's a slight
curvature there,
and the supermarket we're
supplying doesn't allow that.
They have to be
perfectly straight."
These ones, you can see,
are perfectly straight,
but they're too long to
fit into the containers,
and they're being discarded.
The very best fate that
some of these carrots get
is to be fed to livestock.
That's a sub-optimal
use of resources
to put it mildly.
Go one step down
the supply chain
to the manufacturers.
When you buy that
loaf of sliced bread,
I want a show of hands
who lives in a household
where somebody eats the first
and last slice of the loaf?
Most people.
But when you go to a
supermarket or Pret a Manger,
or one of the other
shops that provide you
with these sandwiches
that are ready-made
and very often delicious,
saves you a lot of hassle.
I mean, making a
sandwich is pretty tricky
to do at home, right?
( audience laughter )
Okay, have you ever seen
one of those sandwiches
with a crust on it?
So, I kept on thinking what
happens to all these crusts?
( audience laughter )
Surely, they turn
them into bread crumbs
or some other thing.
We've come up with
loads of different ways
of using odds and ends of bread,
and in our traditional cuisines.
Do you eat bread and butter
pudding in the States?
We have a lovely dessert
with raisins and cream.
Anyway, there's lots of things
you can do with this bread
so I assumed the
industrial, efficient
production systems had
come up with something.
Unfortunately, I found
that wasn't the case.
13,000 slices of fresh
bread being discarded
from a single factory every day.
Multiply that out to all
the other sandwich factories
that exist in the world.
17 percent of every loaf
going into this factory
was being lost,
17 percent of the fields
growing that wheat.
You may as well pick
them up into space
and chuck them away 'cause
that's what we're doing
when we chuck away this food.
So we set about
campaigning about this.
First of all, I wrote my book,
and that exposed
the global figures.
I knew that 350 pages of
densely-argued, data-rich book
was only going to
reach a certain sector
of the population,
an important sector, the
ones making decisions,
but I knew I had to take
this message to the millions,
high-profile,
public-facing campaigns.
I'd always fed
myself out of waste.
I thought, "What would it
be like to feed 5,000 people
out of waste?
What would it be
like to bring together
all the organizations
who have come up
with solutions to this problem
whether it's redistribution
organizations,
campaigning organizations,
people who like ugly
fruit and vegetables,
bring them all together, have
a massive festival, ( laughter )
get loads of press attention,
get this into the press."
That is going to change
the minds of the CEOs
who make decisions about what
ugly fruit and vegetables
should look like.
Since then, we've come up
with a lot of great formats.
Disco Soup was something
we first tried in 2012
in Paris at our Feeding
The 5,000 Event,
and we had 2,000 people in
front of the Hotel de Ville
dancing in the rain
whilst chopping all these
ugly fruit and vegetables
and turning them
into fruit salad and salad.
It got a lot of attention,
and Disco Soup since
then has become a format
that's spread around the world.
I'll give you a taste
of what it feels like
to be at one of our events.
( piano music )
(Event's host):
Ladies and gentlemen,
Big Ben is sounding 12 o'clock.
Welcome to Feeding The 5,000!
Well, Feeding The 5,000
is about a really good
partnership between a
number of organizations
to really try and raise
awareness of the issue
of food waste both
from retailers,
from consumers, from a
whole range of people.
(Event's host): We want
to feed 5,000 people,
but we also want to
feed you with food
that would otherwise be wasted.
The food that you're
being offered today
is stuff that goes
into landfills.
It's perfectly acceptable.
It's good grub, but
what we have got
is we've got stuff that
the supermarkets say no to,
and consumers say no to.
In this country, we
waste so much surplus,
fit-for-consumption food, and
it should be going to people.
With our population increase,
we're getting to the point that
food waste, it's ridiculous
especially in the U.K.
Yeah, hopefully things like
this will raise awareness
and stop food waste
in the future.
Friends of the Earth
are here to demonstrate
how much food that can't
be used for humans,
can be used for animals.
So we've got some
live pigs that we're
actually feeding the waste
from apple pressing today.
The visitors here today
are going to drink
the apple juice,
and then the pressed apples
are actually being fed
to our pigs as well.
So it there to demonstrate
a much more efficient way
of using food so it
doesn't go to waste.
60 million tons of
food waste are being
thrown away every year.
For the average
family, they could save
50 pounds a month simply
by making the most
with the food they buy.
(Event's host): The vegetables
that are being used for lunch
are mulch, all right?
'Cause basically
there are issues,
but they are fresh
and very tasty.
All these carrots are not
suitable for supermarkets,
wrong size, wrong shape.
So just highlighting
the unnecessary waste
of food here today.
Getting people to
help bag stuff up,
and then we can deliver
it off to charities.
I've being a freegan
for 30 years.
Such a crazy world that
we live in at the moment
with so much food wasted,
and so much starvation in the
other parts of the planet.
We need to all respond
to this by saying,
"Look, the global
food waste scandal
whereby we waste
a third of the entire
world's food supply is
something that we can solve."
It's causing
environmental destruction.
It's contributing
to global hunger,
but the solutions are delicious,
and that involves
eating and enjoying food
rather than throwing it away.
( applause )
Thank you.
They're great fun and,
moreover, they get
a lot of press.
That is what puts
pressure on the companies
and the governments who
can change the policies
regarding food waste.
One of the lessons
that I learned
when I studied what was
happening with regard
to food waste in America,
is you have gleaning networks.
You have volunteers actually
going to these farms,
collecting some of
this reject produce
and getting it to hungry people.
No one was doing it in Europe
so instead of promoting another
organization's activities,
we set it up ourself.
Since then, it's been replicated
in other European countries,
and we've been commissioned
by the European Commission
to take it to other countries.
It's a great way also of
getting the message out
about the causes
of this food waste,
and what we can do to tackle it.
I am really keen to
bring Feeding The 5,000
to the United States.
We're in conversations
with a number
of different organizations
who want to tell us
what the priorities
here should be.
Portion sizes are one of them.
Portion sizes in the
United States are shocking.
( audience laughter )
This is some global
data I generated
when I wrote my book.
What it shows is the food supply
that is actually available
to every population
in every country in the world.
Essentially, to cut
a long story short,
it shows that in America
there are twice as many
calories available to eat
as is actually required.
That obviously is a
public health disaster.
It's an environmental disaster,
and it's a huge opportunity
'cause if we can
bring that down,
we can bring down
the food footprint
of the United States.
We can bring down the
problems of obesity,
and we can bring down
the environmental impact
of food production
simply by avoiding
producing, selling, eating
too much food.
It's good for everyone.
It saves money.
It saves the planet.
I think that we can stop
wasting so much food,
and it's going to be tasty.
Thank you very much.
(applause)
( outro music )